chanter pour sauver l'environnement
chanter à côté des arbres pour communier
avec la nature c'est la proposition de
plusieurs partenaires qui ont décidé de
faire vivre autrement cette
sensibilisation pour la sauvegarde de la
planète
nous sommes ici à mascara le jardin
botanique de la réunion où le projet est
simple et pourtant rempli de richesse
humaine patrimoniale et surtout
environnementale des en fait au départ
on a réuni plusieurs personnes notamment
des musiciens des cauris et aussi au
jardin botanique
l'idée de départ est toujours la même
c'est comment aujourd'hui dans un jardin
pouvoir attirer deux publics différents
soit par d'autres activités comme les
arts le sport ou autre
et l'idée première était aussi d'aller
vers la jeunesse aujourd'hui comme le
tout est plus réduit on va pas chercher
les six mois on va chercher 3 si j'ai
pas mal d arbres à découvrir et des
arbres ou se percher et voir le monde de
là où on y ajoutant du champ la belle
idée est née l'année dernière sous forme
d'une ode à la musique world chanteur la
partition et rejouer cette année le
principe de vos chanteurs c'est de faire
rencontrer des artistes et des classes
donc qui sont en formation chorale le
but c'est de leur apprendre des chants
un univers musical et l'originalité
c'est de lier en fait ce projet
artistique à un projet environnemental
ce projet c'est la deuxième édition et
c'est le principe était remontée des
marmailles dans les arbres de leur
permettre de faire une représentation
sur leur travail deux chorales avec le
groupe graines semées au départ car audi
sakho et voilà non par le projet et ont
fait l'installation g d'arbres pour la
deuxième année successive carlo de sakho
est de nouveau là avec rennes sait mais
le chanteur veut parler aux plus jeunes
avec des textes qui racontent la réunion
mais aussi comment revenir à l'essentiel
à ce qui nous lie avec nous même et avec
les autres
c'est toujours une découverte toujours
un même plaisir
déjà parce qu'il montre avec des
marmailles et que ben c'est toujours
c'est toujours souriant de travailler
avec des enfants
et puis parce que ben dans notre société
actuelle je pense que c'est les enfants
c'est l'école qu'elle à la chose la
pierre angulaire de des futurs du futur
de la planète
donc nous a fait grincer mais on on
c'est une priorité de travail et que les
enfants grandissent et mais qui transmet
qui touche profondément les jeunes
enfants qui ont travaillé les textes et
répété avec le chanteur carlo de ça
qu'on ait découvert qu'on pouvait
raconter des chazelles à partir d'une
histoire femme pouvait raconter des
choses à part ça c'est une chanson il
racontait l'histoire d'un gramoune la
réunion et c'est toujours intéressant de
connaître l'histoire a comme ça que oui
de plantes et de faire des choses graves
et fois de répondre sur la nature un
travail qui a commencé au sort des
établissements scolaires puisque ce sont
quatre classes qui ont été retenues pour
ce projet de casse de la chaloupe et
deux classes de trois bassins de 6e et
de 5e
on a travaillé donc sur les textes en
place donc on a récupéré nous envoyer au
combat par mail des bandes son
des versions chantées et donc nous on a
travaillé là dessus et aujourd'hui c'est
la première des conditions donc avec
l'artiste est donc ici au jardin
botanique des jeunes choristes qui
seront présents pour le festival en
extérieur du leu tempo qui se tiendra du
4 cette semaine
l'année dernière ce sont des paroles des
textes d'alain peters qui ont résonné
cette année les jeunes choristes
reprendront les chansons de grincer mais
dans ce cadre magnifique où tous les
sens sont en éveil
même si soleil la peau fathi ben ali